[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
yellowjackets episode nine
doom coming i am going to split my
review into two parts we'll start with
the present day storyline first and then
we'll end with what's going on in the
wilderness so we see with the present
day storyline shauna is confronting adam
right where we left off where the
episode ended last week and
what's interesting about this reveal is
we finally get an answer about adam yet
all these theories that adam is javi and
it turns out the people who thought it
was jeff were correct that he was the
blackmailer what was interesting about
this whole sequence was that it was
awakening the shauna from the wilderness
in this scene which i thought was really
well done i do wish though they had
shown some different footage from stuff
we haven't seen yet with shauna in the
woods so it would kind of leave more
theories to be made about where to go
but because it's the end of the season
they probably didn't film that stuff yet
so we'll see maybe for season two i also
thought it was a little silly that sean
even mentions the code of the safe is
the flight number any fanboy could
figure that out so why would shawna make
that the code that didn't make much
sense to me that was kind of stupid but
i really do believe this definitely
confirms adam was never javi because i
believe him when he's saying
he didn't even know who she was before
the accident and that we see that it's
like a little misdirect when she finds
the book on the yellow jackets but he
was just doing what anyone would do when
they first start dating someone was
looking into them but we find out about
jeff we don't just find out he's a
blackmailer we find out that he was
specifically blackmailing taissa and nat
because the furniture business was going
out but he also knew about shauna and
her journals and what she
i guess did in the woods that's in those
journals so he never told her that but
it's interesting that he still stayed
with her and didn't bring it up and
what's ironic about this whole thing is
that this is the dirty laundry that
shawn and jeff had to air to each other
this whole episode that's happening here
and it actually brings them closer all
the lying they've been doing to each
other's coming to the surface and it's
almost like they connect more about
being liars and that kind of makes them
really work together and then people
predicted as well
that
jeff wasn't actually having an affair
that this woman he was talking to was
something else turns out her name is
bianca she's part of these
lone bad people shauna calls them so
that's going to be interesting and i'm
sure those people are going to have a
part in all of this and they clearly
have to know
that jeff is obviously married to shauna
a yellowjacket one of the hysterical
lines there's many hysterical moments in
this episode in general but shauna says
i can't believe you thought i was going
to book club this whole time and jeff
says what there was no book club i
thought that was great what i do like is
that jeff has this moment that actually
really impresses shauna because he's
willing to go down for all this for
shauna but shauna makes a great point
that it doesn't even matter if he did
that because it's all going to trace
back to the blackmailing then the
journals then what they did in the
wilderness the yellow jackets she does
not want that happening and this is a
nice reminder of the stakes here in
present day which i liked because she
says in portland that her daughter's
life would be over so this is also
establishing that at all costs shauna in
present day does not want this
yellowjacket information getting out and
it's a good reason why to protect her
family another important little thing
they threw in here was that jeff told
one other person about the blackmail
which was randy walsh now we saw him
momentarily in present day but he is the
idiot jackie tried setting shauna up
with at the party so that's also going
to be a big thing and it's going to
bring randy walsh into this story and
some nice writing here when shauna says
to jeff when do we become these people
who lie and cheat and do awful things
and jeff says we have always been these
people secrets have become
a part of us and what i love about this
is the best part about it is the next
line is
you thought this dead guy was
blackmailing you so why can't the other
girls too so it's like so why not just
keep up the lying at this point but what
i'm talking about too is when we learn
that jeff had read these journals he's
saying to shauna like you guys are so
young i know this was traumatizing and
again this does make it seem like it's
the closest we've seen jeff and shauna
in this show and she likes that he's
understanding of it now shauna goes and
lies to nat
and
taisso when
they show up to see this dead body of
adam saying he's the blackmailer melanie
linski who's been doing great work this
whole show does great in particular in
the scene at doing a lie and hiding it a
little bit in her face that she is lying
but she's still an incredible liar this
character of shauna she's covering all
of her tracks to all the questions that
taissa and natalie are throwing her way
nice little touch too by the actress
malinsky when she's playing sean here
because she mentions i thought he loved
me i trusted him and there is this
little like regret she feels and sadness
because yeah she killed the wrong guy
here you know so she lost someone that
she did have feelings for but what's
important to realize is that we know
jeff was a black member but we don't
know who actually killed travis and
natalie makes this point you really
think this guy is the guy who killed
travis talking about adam but just in
general that there's another layer to
this here and it's interesting because
what's gonna have natalie catch on to
shauna lying which is gonna cause huge
conflict is that natalie still has her
former sponsor working on that bank
account that was closed that was travis
so that's gonna kind of connect more
dots here for natalie and be more
suspicious of shauna another great
hysterical line was when taissa says we
can't leave him here and shauna says
well we can't exactly weakened him at
bernie's out the door that was great and
going to a theme that goes through this
episode
is when they make the point here that
there's dna everywhere this isn't just
get rid of the body situation this is a
complicated situation they need help and
this is when they need misty and that
theme that we're seeing is that they
only have missing out when they need her
so let's switch over to misty land here
and we see
the reporter she has tied up has now
upgraded from the bed to actually
sitting up in the chair and what this
reporter who knows way more than she's
leaning on is doing with misty in this
episode is playing to her good side and
her weaknesses and bringing up how close
they were on this island and why didn't
they keep in touch with you you guys
have been off there for 25 years and
really just hitting at misty soft spot
and where it gets a little crazy here is
that misty is putting on this lipstick
like she does in the past with jackie
here and it's someone showing her a
different way right and how easy it is
to influence misty the reporter is
manipulating her that way and it just
wants her to speak out to this ghost
writer to talk about what happened the
reporter says this line you guys did eat
each other right and she's like they
won't blame you you're just trying to
survive they're going to sympathize with
the person who actually spoke and missy
says when we first came back we couldn't
get help we couldn't betray the group
but now time to tell the truth so
everyone can heal so i really do believe
misty was considering this again she's
easy to kind of sway and influence if
you say the right things to her and we
see that throughout this episode in both
timelines but she is stopped the perfect
timing of her actually considering this
bad idea in general is because nat shows
up right in time and this takes a lot of
nat literally lying through her teeth
about how much she is sorry to miss
seeing how she sees her as a friend
and she keeps complimenting her but it
works again telling you how easy is to
just
sway misty and how she can flip back and
forth so fast it's perfect timing
because now she informs her they need
help with the body and it makes me think
now that too late for the reporter now
she was close but misty's gonna side
with natalie and that team just again to
feel wanted and liked and get rid of
that body so i do not think this
reporter is gonna make it through this
finale period so let's go to where it
was really interesting is flashback
timeline here in the woods and to sum up
the plot here jackie literally says in
the beginning you know it's doom coming
we'll drink rotten berries and celebrate
our impending death what was so cool is
going to get ready going crazy is seeing
everyone kind of crafting their outfits
for the first time that we see later on
in the story and lottie's holding those
antlers as we'll see later on she
actually wears these things we're going
to get into that though but they did a
good job of writing young misty here
where she asked ben to the dance and he
reluctantly says yes but he brings up
the boundaries here and that anything
else wouldn't be right but this is where
misty says i understand but she really
doesn't and she's gonna have this plot
to use these magic mushrooms to get what
she wants with him and what i love so
much is jackie's story in this episode
because i can relate and i think many
people can relate that when you're
growing up and you're in your teens
you know you can have such a positive
outlook on the world like jackie did
before they got to the woods and the
minute she found out the information
about what shawna did behind her back
her faith in humanity her view of the
world has completely changed she has no
f's given she's completely pessimistic
it's like a different person like
culture shock for somebody and i
remember in life i've had that moment
too where you find something bad someone
you you really thought was good maybe
did something wrong and the world isn't
so black and white as you thought and i
think they do a really good job of
hitting that here and it's interesting
to watch with jackie because she's in a
special case where this part in your
life is happening but she's starving in
the woods while it's happening so it's
even amplified right she has no parents
to talk to and she's refusing to eat
even at this point but you see shauna
still cares about her is looking out for
her throughout this episode telling her
to eat and even suggesting smartly like
hey don't rock the boat with travis here
because you're gonna piss off the other
yellow jackets again this is a group
here they look out for each other and
that's just a no-no you know messing
with someone else's man even though they
did break up still a little too soon and
they had such little attention detail
nice touches i loved here where lottie
is wearing laura lee's dress to the
dance and i love this little romantic
story they have with van and ty where
vance self-conscious about her face but
tai makes up for that by making them
have the similar masks that cover half
the face and you even see her too shawn
is more pregnant we know this because
she's having trouble zipping up her
dress and the zipping up the dress where
she needs help leads to misty leaving
the magic mushrooms on the table for it
to be put in the stew and it done gets
really good payoff with the writing here
that jackie's not eating and it serves
the plot because that is the reason
jackie wouldn't take the stew she's the
only one who didn't have it and little
details too again everything's serving
her purpose here and meaning more than
you're actually seeing and i like that
coach ben who we know is gay but he's in
the closet is proud of ty and van for
them kissing and coming out basically to
everybody and he even says that so it is
motivating to him to do that and i love
when misty's like responding to jackie
saying let's get a dj going she's like
we need a slow dance it looks at ben
it's just great and where stuff starts
really to hit the fan is actually when
they start singing seal kister moroes
great song obviously perfect song to
pick from this timeline and
misty's rejected a dance by ben and then
this is the same moment nat sees travis
starting to dance with jackie so things
start to get shaken up here and it makes
sense that nat and ben would be the ones
to kind of hang out here so it also is
when the shrooms start to hit it starts
with ben and nat and i love that natalie
starts doing the hand thing from the
rebecca black video and i love that
misty now and her sadness just you know
pouring down the rotten berries down her
throat but it is symbolic obviously all
over her face like the blood that's
gonna be your face from eating people
and poor javi here is just
tripping his balls just laying down on
the ground you know he's the youngest
one there this stuff's got to be hitting
him hard and it makes sense because you
got to have him at that level to justify
him not you know sticking up for travis
or even understand what the hell is
going on with travis and during this
episode now you have to remember the
thing the show keeps toying with you and
they do it so well is how much of this
is supernatural if any because every
situation we've seen that could be
supernatural it also could be justified
as you know they're just tripping or
they're hallucinating right so like lady
at one point is like shh do you feel
that when they start tripping so it
starts a chain of events everyone's
saying they feel this energy from the
ground this is again eluding the
supernatural part of the show and lottie
obviously the one who pushes this the
most and connects to it the most now
shout out to ella parnell who's been
obviously killing it as jackie but she
has this great moment a little bit of
monologuing here with travis when travis
confesses to her that he loves nat and
we get to really see inside jackie's
head when talking about that theme like
you're so sweet and i even dumb she's
calling him it's basically her talking
to her old self and she's talking about
how even the jackie before the crash was
just excited the next day to have a
soccer game and i love how she delivers
the line you just feel where she's like
shauna was effing jeff best friend
having sex with my boyfriend behind my
back and you see her mindset friendship
doesn't matter love doesn't matter none
of this matters shells with nothing
inside i will say we don't want to talk
about the antler queen stuff with lottie
that we've seen but that still could be
a red herring communism is just a red
herring it could be something that's
also passed to somebody else but i do
think this line by jackie in her state
of mind does make me give a little more
weight to people who maybe think she
might end up being the ultimate antler
queen the other day because she is
talking like someone who's going down a
bad path so lottie is the one who
connects travis and jackie are missing
and she's like we should find them he
doesn't belong to her and now they're
all going into this animalistic mode
it's a nice touch when they hear the
wolves they're like a pack of wolves
themselves and we're in full lord of the
flies mode here and like lord of the
flies like the story with simon and lord
of the flies this at the end of the day
is
in the
territory of being an accident because
shauna even when they're attacking
travis is seeing him as a stag so
it's like in lord of the flies where
they see simon they think he's a monster
and that's why they end up killing him
so it's falling that same category so
you see the inspiration and it was such
great suspense when they're coming
to travis and jackie while travis and
jackie are having sex it was edited
really well and where stuff gets again
more into the supernatural stuff is when
they get there and put jackie in the
closet you know lottie says this has
nothing to do with natalie and jack even
has that line it's not like the spirits
care so it's alluding to stuff there's a
lot going on here and it's going to add
to more theories of like what is this
crazy talk that lottie's having you know
what's is it at the end of the day just
them being on these poison berries also
starving and also on mushrooms at the
same time but you know in this scene
with travis he's tripping so you can
still justify us because of the tripping
but he's seeing them almost like
demonically possessed so is there this
possession supernatural element involved
with this and let me just tell you
okay
this actor of travis is the luckiest man
on the face of the earth and if you
literally know anyone in your life who
is questioning if he should become an
actor or a baseball player
just show them this scene okay because
my god i mean he must have been in a
different world god bless him and there
was great horror here with shauna
pulling travis's skin
uh horrifying so i'm glad it was leaning
to the horror like this and like i said
remember they're running after travis
because they think he is a stag lottie
says go after the stag and
i love the blend of mood here because
while this is happening all this
craziness then you know what ty and van
i have this actually really beautiful
romantic moment where they're in the
woods having sex and she's like you know
take off the mask i want to see you it
was just great but i think it's
important that they were not with lottie
at that moment and
like i'm going to go into it at the end
we're gonna see a group divide here we
have to after this big incident and i
think that could set up who's in what
group by who's actually with lottie in
that moment and i also love in this
writing when out when ben and nat are at
like full peak tripping you know they're
talking about love being the reason
they're here and it inspires nat to go
run after travis and it inspires missy
to then go to ben and she's like you're
so right and shout out to the actor of
ben the way he tells misty he is gay and
he says
i'm gay gay gay gay i was dying how he
delivered that line it was just great
great comedic delivery and it quickly
transitioned obviously to sadness
because he's talking about how hear that
you know family i'm gay so it was just
really worked and again like i'm talking
about there's so many different moods
and feelings you have during all this
last 20 minutes episode so it was
exciting to watch okay so the big
moments when they catch up to travis
right we see lottie's putting on the
antler queen thing now if you talk to me
if you know me i've been saying it's a
lot easy on the queen since the episode
we saw she was hearing voices uh and i
had said in my last review so i'm like
okay you know i'm in team lottie be
another queen it looks like we're right
but it could still be a red herring
communism is just a red herring they
could still be toying with you and also
there could be a thing where that she
does become the antler queen here and
it's still not the exact antler queen
that we see in the you know future
flashbacks when they're eating people
because that could be just it passed
down to somebody else that it's just a
role that gets moved so we'll see but
it's really looking like lottie and you
see what i'm talking about the
supernatural element lottie says to
shauna when she's got the knife at
travis's neck she's seeing it as a stag
she's like it's okay if it wants you to
whatever this entity is or again maybe
they're just tripping and also lottie
isn't taking her meds we can't forget
that little detail because they kind of
want you to forget we can't so that's
important and you see natalie shows up
saves the day and lottie's like it's in
all of us you know even him even you so
this shows me a divide all i can say
there's got to be divide after a big
moment like this it's not going to be
the same and i think that that divide
starts with natalie versus lottie i
think
in the storyline natalie has kind of to
me shown the most good uh yes she has a
problem with drugs but i do think she
has a good heart about her and i think
that's going to show a divide of lottie
who's someone who's just out of her mind
right now and obviously nat cares about
travis and will not be happy about this
and it's so interesting we have not seen
adult lottie and
they're i have a feeling and we also
haven't seen adult jackie like yes the
mom has said she's dead but we don't
really really know that right and
i think that the finale will probably
end the season cliffhanger of someone or
maybe the whole episode might just
appear at the beginning where there's
gonna be an adult person we haven't seen
yet there has to be and it has to be
someone maybe who's involved with
travis's death but
i'm giving this penalty episode a 9.1 i
thought it was really well done i still
think it's the second best episode after
episode 7 with the wolves but it still
was great
i think maybe the present day story can
come off a little silly at times but
that's fine i don't think that's that's
a little nitpick um i maybe could see
people being let down about the reveal
of how they handled the blackmailer that
we took you know nine episodes and a lot
of screen time with adam and shauna just
to find out he's really not really
anybody so that could be frustrating it
doesn't justify again where i said
episode four was the worst episode so
damn slow
um because it was a whole date of adam
and shauna basically so i don't see why
that was a thing still this doesn't help
that case but anyway really enjoyed it
loved the performances here love the
stuff how they're going with the story
with jackie and shauna and it's going to
be fascinating to see what happens with
his body and misty i cannot wait for
this finale but you know let me know you
thought i read every comment and try to
respond as many as they can i want to
hear all your theories let's just get
the discussion going uh please follow me
at steve barley show on twitter
instagram and tick tock for more of me
i'll see you next time